[Música]
hola bienvenidos a este especial de
noticias de france 24 soy marina sardiña
el impulso de la ola verde se extendió
por todo el continente latinoamericano
con algunos avances pero también con
retrocesos este año ha sido clave para
los derechos sexuales y reproductivos de
las mujeres latinoamericanas y el debate
ha estado en la agenda de muchos estados
gracias a la lucha feminista veamos una
radiografía regional sobre el acceso a
la interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
en 6 países de la región el aborto está
totalmente penalizado desde haití
nicaragua honduras hasta el salvador
donde recientemente la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos
condenó al estado por encarcelar a
manuel a una mujer que sufrió un aborto
espontáneo consecuencia de una
emergencia obstétrica
en el resto de latinoamérica el aborto
está criminalizado pero con algunas
excepciones en venezuela y guatemala
sólo está permitido bajo el supuesto de
riesgo para la vida de la mujer en costa
rica y perú también se permite cuando la
salud física está en riesgo mientras que
en panamá y ecuador brasil o chile
depende de varios supuestos como la
violación incesto amenaza para la vida
salud física o mental de la mujer o
viabilidad del feto a finales de
noviembre en la cámara de diputados
chilena rechazó la despenalización
completa del aborto hasta las 14 semanas
y el proyecto quedará archivado la
situación en bolivia y colombia es otra
el aborto legal está basado en un
sistema de causales pero sigue estando
dentro del código penal
en méxico es legal en siete de los 32
estados pero este año la corte suprema
de justicia emitió una decisión
histórica declarando que abortar no
constituye un delito y por último el
aborto es legal en seis países cuba
uruguay puerto rico guayana guayana
francesa y más recientemente argentina
para hablar sobre la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo y el panorama
regional latinoamericano tenemos con
nosotros desde argentina absolvieron
abogada de la organización el equipo
latinoamericano de justicia y género e
integrante de la red acceso al aborto
seguro en argentina redaf bienvenida
también quiero saludar a rebeca ramos de
la ong de que nos acompaña desde mexico
ella es la directora de la organización
feminista gire grupo de información en
reproducción elegida gracias por estar
con nosotras
me gustaría preguntarle qué supone la
interrupción del embarazo que está
criminalizada en gran parte del
continente
bueno por un lado supone empujar a las
mujeres a la clandestinidad porque si no
pueden acceder
en un marco de legalidad al aborto en
los distintos países eso significa que
de alguna manera acceden de una forma
que podría ser insegura y que podría
poner en riesgo su vida o su salud en
que ha comprobado que la criminalización
del aborto no y no significa que las
mujeres dejen de abortar sino justamente
que lo hagan en un marco que puede
suponer acceder a una a un aborto en
condiciones inseguras
por otro lado si no digo no lo iba a
decir por otro lado también la
criminalización del aborto deja hemos en
una situación complicada a las y los
profesionales de la salud comprometidos
con garantizar el acceso a la salud de
las personas porque también los los
empuja dilemas éticos vinculados a
cuando deberían o no garantizar un
derecho que deberían poder tener
libertad para garantizar el en término
general
y en muchos países rebeca de la región
está legalizado dentro de un sistema de
causales es esto suficiente para hacer
del aborto un derecho
no lamentablemente el
sistema de causal es lo que lo que
significa es que de entrada el aborto es
considerado un delito y en ciertas
circunstancias por ejemplo cuando el
embarazo es producto de una violación
sexual cuando está en riesgo la salud de
la persona gestante entonces ahí no se
va a considerar un delito pero
precisamente con conectó con esto que
decía sobrepone a las mujeres y a las
personas que requieren una interrupción
del embarazo pero también a los
profesionales de la salud en una
situación complicada en una situación
confusa y es por eso que la marea verde
y que la exigencia del aborto legal
seguro y gratuito
pide y exige a los estados que
despenalicen el aborto y que pasemos de
un sistema de causales a un sistema de
plazos por lo menos entonces sí me
parece que es muy importante tener esto
claro en lo que lo que sucedió en
argentina hace ya casi un año es un es
un avance enorme lo vemos por ejemplo en
méxico en donde en ciudad de méxico
desde 2007 tenemos un sistema de plazos
y eso ha permitido un mayor acceso a los
servicios de salud y precisamente que el
aborto se ve en términos de derechos y
no en términos de un delito de una
excepción
dependiendo de determinadas situaciones
si precisamente de argentina
pasamos de la clandestinidad al congreso
gracias a esta marea verde sobre qué
está pasando ahora hay que pasar este
último año en argentina
bueno este último año además de estar
muy contentas por la graduación y por el
avance en garantizar y reconocer los
derechos humanos de las mujeres y
personas gestantes en el desafío web
'www el foco en la implementación estuvo
puesto más que nada en fortalecer las
capacidades de
digamos de los servicios sanitarios del
país que todo el país también en la
encuesta de nuestro federalismo que al
igual que la colega de méxico significa
algunos desafíos en términos de
implementación de normas sanitarias
también estuvo el foco en remover
ciertas barreras que existían en
capacitar a profesionales de la salud
que quizás no estaban garantizando en el
marco de nuestro sistema
previo que era un sistema de causales y
también en proveer los insumos
necesarios para que se pueda garantizar
en todo el territorio del país ahí esto
es un poco el foco en la implementación
y desde nuestro rol como sociedad civil
estuvo en defender la y en garantiza
intentar garantizar o intentar que no
existan retrocesos en términos
jurisprudencial es porque hubo mucho él
y yo en contra de la ley con
posterioridad a su sanción
rebeca en septiembre la corte de
justicia de méxico declaró
inconstitucional criminalizar el aborto
en el país que exhibe ahora para las
mujeres mexicanas
pues fue sin lugar a duda una sentencia
histórica es la primera vez que la corte
revisa precisamente la criminalización
del aborto voluntario
absoluto hay que decir que precisamente
por nuestro sistema federal en méxico
cada uno de los estados de la república
tienen la potestad de regular que
consideran un delito y que no y esta
decisión de la suprema corte se refirió
única y exclusivamente al caso del
estado de coahuila un estado del norte
que hace frontera con texas y ahí fue
donde la corte emitió este precedente
que no nos permite que se despenaliza el
aborto de manera automática en todo el
país pero si queda un precedente y unos
argumentos jurídicos muy fuertes para
avanzar en la despenalización en el
resto del país apenas después de esta
después de esta sentencia y ya son dos
estados quienes despenalizan el aborto
durante el primer trimestre de la
gestación en las 12 primeras semanas
baja california y apenas el miércoles te
pasado hace unos días el estado de
colima entonces no se está dando
argumentos muy poderosos que ya veníamos
trabajando en las organizaciones
feministas desde desde hace años pero
bueno que lo diga el tribunal
constitucional de la nación es muy
importante y pues lo que sí es seguir
empujando para que se saque de los
códigos penales el aborto y sobre todo
para que se dé el acceso en los
servicios de salud abortos legales
seguros y gratuitos un poco tenemos pues
los mismos retos que ya comentaba la
colega de argentina en términos de
implementación y que se haga una
realidad para quienes lo requieran
soy rebeca os invito a ver ahora un caso
particular un testimonio particular aquí
en colombia desde hace más de cinco
décadas la antropóloga y activista
feminista judith botero ayuda a las
mujeres colombianas a acceder a abortos
seguros desde la clandestinidad siendo
un ejemplo para las feministas más
jóvenes en colombia desde 2006 la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo es
legal bajo tres causales sin embargo se
estima que cada año se realizan más de
400.000 abortos pero menos del 10 son de
forma legal debido en parte al
conservadurismo y la religión en
colombia hay unos 5 mil procesos penales
abiertos contra mujeres y niñas la
mayoría residentes en zonas rurales
conozcamos la historia de esta pionera
feminista el derecho a la reproducción
es también el derecho a no reproducirse
en algo tan trascendental como es traer
un hijo o una hija al mundo yo creo con
un hijo o una hija se trae al mundo
primero que todo porque se desea el
deseo está atravesado también por las
posibilidades sociales culturales y de
afecto un hijo o una hija tiene por lo
menos el derecho a no ser querido amado
y ningún estado puede resolver esto
décadas antes de que la marea verde
sacudiera américa latina' en colombia
judith botero ayudaba a las mujeres que
sufrían abortos incompletos era 1986
cuando ingreso a la organización salud
mujer dos años más tarde cerraron debido
a las amenazas de la iglesia que cuando
tuvimos que cerrar eso las mujeres eran
en lo que es ideas porque el trabajo ahí
es en donde el portón
así sea muy negado para cada mujer a
nivel individual el aborto cuando lonnie
tal buscas lo sabe bien judith madre de
cuatro hijos y dos abortos clandestinos
cuando la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo no salía del ámbito privado
debido al yugo religioso y el
conservadurismo ideológico ya no anaya
yo lo tenía muy claro así me muriera yo
tenía un carro que otro hijo manu tenía
durante su pionera lucha por este
derecho audite y sus compañeras atendían
a mujeres y niñas de sectores
empobrecidos en el departamento de
antioquia en el no residente de colombia
mujeres pudiendo en niños y familias
huérfanas porque la mujer se había hecho
un aborto o mutiladas porque había que
sacar esto por las infecciones cada año
mueren unas 70 mujeres en el país y más
de 1300 sufren complicaciones debido a
la clandestinidad y los métodos
precarios si lo que más veíamos era eso
ondas de sonda musicales
si metían un agua con sal
agujas de malla cebollas cebolla junca
que las ramas y se la metían a la puerta
por ejemplo la sonda ese canal la metían
sin ninguna indicación ni nada sino
antes los daños eran que viví en 2006 la
corte constitucional tomó una decisión
sin precedentes despenalizar el aborto
bajo tres causales con la sentencia
c-355 un avance que no estuvo ajeno a
los obstáculos sobre todo para las
mujeres rurales afros indígenas
inmigrantes en un principio a los
médicos pues que lo hacían cada ninguno
de las mujeres podían ir con la causa
más clara y no afuera de eso la amenaza
que se van a morir que el aborto es muy
peligroso que ustedes pueden morir que
bajar ahí sí que bajar huérfanos todo
mentiras a finales de este año la corte
constitucional dejó en el limbo jurídico
dos demandas que buscaban eliminar el
delito del aborto del código penal
dejando en standby el derecho sexual y
reproductivo de las colombianas que no
pueden esperar más por ahora lo más lo
más importante es de finalizarlo porque
siguen habiendo alpes hay en más hay más
mujeres en este momento
penalizadas que cuando estábamos en la
con destino a unas 400 mujeres son
criminalizadas por abortar anualmente el
97 por ciento procedentes rurales las
discriminaciones para las que están más
vulnerados en la vida desde que
nació es que toda la vida el aborto ha
existido y las ricas de este país iban
para el extranjero toda la vida
y las ponga de moda hoy son las nietas
de esta feminista las que siguen su
legado clamando por el derecho a ser
madres con libertad repitiendo su lema
nuestro cuerpo el primer territorio soy
me gustaría hacer una breve conclusión
qué opina cuál crees que es el panorama
para las feministas que están luchando
por este derecho en esta región
bueno yo creo que el panorama es
prometedor en términos de la
visibilización del tema del empuje el
compromiso de los movimientos feministas
y de mujeres y de las nuevas
generaciones de movimientos que que no
dudan en tomar las calles y en reclamar
sus derechos para que efectivamente se
avance en términos normativos y el
desafío es de alguna manera
que este empuje y que esta esta
iniciativa de avanzar en el
reconocimiento de derechos también
encuentra barreras y obstáculos
vinculados a sectores los sectores más
conservadores de las sociedades y ese es
un desafío que vamos a tener en la
implementación de normas así como
también en la canción o aprobación de
norma rebeca y qué opina usted desde
méjico
y yo coincido con con su me parece que
hemos avanzado mucho lo que ha
significado la marea verde en la región
no tiene precedentes esta movilización
social tener un símbolo como lo es el el
pañuelo verde que nos congrega a todos
para exigir aborto legal y seguro
entonces en ese sentido soy soy
optimista pero sin lugar a dudas hay
resistencias muy fuertes en términos de
cambios normativos en algunos países
como en ciertos lugares ley de méxico
pero también en términos del acceso a
los servicios de salud entonces ahí pues
el reto es grande pero pero las
organizaciones las activistas las
colectivas las acompañantes de aborto
seguro tenemos muy claro cuál es nuestro
nuestro objetivo y pues no vamos a dejar
de exigir ni dejar de trabajar hasta que
el aborto legal seguro y gratuito sea
una realidad para todas aquellas
personas que lo necesiten sin importar
su condición social socioeconómica
con esto llegamos al final de nuestro
programa muchas gracias psoe y rebeca
por estar con nosotras para hablar del
aborto recordando que se trata como
reclaman las feministas de un derecho
fundamental y no una obligación a
ustedes gracias por estar con nosotros
pueden ver más en france 24 y france24
puntocom
[Música]